I don't know how you're feeling after
such a magical moment up there I'm
feeling amazing I got to introduce
signing with song for the first time on
a GT stage and that meant a lot to me
and I got to sing an original song again
on the Dolby theatre I mean life is
beautiful right now
[Music]
I'm presenting a song that's very
heartfelt and very raw and so stripping
it down so that you can hear all the
words or see the signs without too much
distraction meant a lot for the meaning
of the song so I'm I'm happy that it was
received as well and then of course
Simon to compare you to Adele this
reminds me the first time I ever heard
Adele say what did that mean to you it's
crazy I've never heard Adele sing so
it's a difficult comparison for me but
you can't not know Adele
she's Adele and I hope that if she sees
the video and here's me saying that
she's not offended by that comparison
it's a great comparison it's a great
comparison and to know that Simon has
her back like that because he's said to
me how special you actually are what
does that mean to you
Simon is is wonderful because he's
listening to my musicianship he's not
trying to get caught up in a pity story
which I don't feel that I am one but
some people would put me in that
category regardless of what happens the
fact that he's looking at me straight on
as a singer means the world because I
want that judgement
[Music]